to Arms wordsmiths this video is about
the word defiant
defiant it's an adjective this word
means openly disobeying rules pushing
back against Authority this word comes
to us from French and ultimately Latin a
late Latin verb dis
fidare which means to renounce to go
back on one's faith fedus is Latin for
Faith or trust and dis means not or away
so with that in mind what are some
English words that you can think of that
contain those elements dis or FID you're
probably wondering about D and D those
are different sounds they mean the exact
same thing in Latin they both mean not
or away I'll give you 10 seconds to
think and then show you what I came up
with here we
[Music]
go
here are some of mine dislike right not
liking something Fidelity which is like
faithfulness or loyalty and confidence
which is like saying you trust yourself
you have faith in yourself let's use it
in a sentence or two in fact let me show
you a couple of forms of this word
because you can use it as a verb as defy
or defies as in Luella defied her father
and snuck out at night and then when we
turn it back into an adjective by adding
that a ant ending we get defiant again
plumaria goodart was defiant she would
never give in to Lady Morant little hoby
woman over here brimming with goodness
big evil sorceress over here crackling
with lightning feel my wrath I'll never
join you etc etc you get the picture to
be defiant is to be bold audacious
rebellious unruly a defiant person
openly flouts rules and fights Authority
so when you want to turn that adjective
defiant into a noun you turn the ant
into a nce defiant becomes Defiance
that's how you talk about it as a noun
let me let me use it in a sentence the
rebels showed their Defiance through
performances of forbidden dance the most
forbidden dance of all is the dance of
neurons blazing through your mind as
they make new connections sparks flying
in the deepness of your mind as your
brain becomes a bright shimmering Beacon
of knowledge the Roomba of rumination
the Bachata of brilliant
the
Lambada of learning you can learn
anything David out